هذا هو المكان الذي
يخبرنا فيه الجيش الأوكراني أنه يستعيد
أراضيهم ،
ولكن على الجبهة الجنوبية المدمرة مع
روسيا
، يبدو أن حالة الجمود في حرب الخنادق
قد بدأت ،
ويعترف القادة بشكل خاص بأن التقدم من قبل أي من الجانبين
هنا صغير
ويبدو أن الروس يجرون.  من
الذخيرة وهم ليسوا أقوياء كما
أخبرني قائد فصيلة هذا الخندق الأمامي ،
لكننا نحتاج إلى المزيد من الأسلحة أيضًا ، ويضيف إذا كان
المكان الذي يجب المضي قدمًا فيه ،
فأنا أتحدث إلى أنطون هنا وهو
يقول
بصوت عالٍ جدًا في  في الليل ،
لذلك في الصباح ، يقول
إنه ليس صاخبًا جدًا ، إنه أكثر هدوءًا بعض الشيء ،
لذا فهو ممتع لأن هذا
هو المكان الذي
تقول فيه الحكومة الأوكرانية أن هناك
هجومًا مضادًا كبيرًا يجري
منذ بعض الوقت ويستعيدون
الأراضي
لكننا لم نر قدرًا كبيرًا من الأدلة
على ذلك
على أرض الواقع ، يبدو أنك تعلم أن
كلا الجانبين المحفورين هنا قد
حاربوا أنفسهم بشدة إلى طريق مسدود ،
ولا يكفي أي من الجانبين
لكسب هذه الحرب
ولكن ليس ضعيفًا بما يكفي لتفقدها ، إما
أن تكون صادرة ،
هل أنت متأكد من
أنهم يستطيعون سماع
قذائف المدفعية الصادرة
تتدفق عبر هذا الموقع
هنا يأخذنا مرافقتنا العسكريون الأوكرانيون
إلى ما يقولون إنها منطقة محررة مؤخرًا
حيث يوجد 30 على الأقل
قُتل الروس المحتجزون داخل روضة الأطفال هذه
بينما تركز موسكو قواتها على دونباس
في شرق أوكرانيا
يقول المسؤولون إن المناطق التي تم احتلالها
في الجنوب مثل
هذه تُركت مكشوفة
جيدًا ، لقد أحضروها إلى هذا
الموقع المتقدم جدًا حيث يمكنك سماع ذلك هناك  لا
تزال عمليات
تبادل نيران المدفعية مستمرة
وهذه
هي بقايا معركة
منذ أسبوعين يقولون أين
اتخذت القوات الأوكرانية هذا الموقف الروسي
بتكلفة كبيرة لكل من الأوكرانيين ومن
الواضح أه للروس
أيضًا  هذا
الحطام على الأرض تم إخبارنا
بالمعدات الروسية ومن الواضح أن هذه
هي بقايا
مركبة مصفحة روسية من نوع ما  لقد
كان
مثل الكثيرين الذين رأيناهم
مدمرين تمامًا في هذا
الصراع المرير ، حيث اعتقد
الروس أنهم سينتصرون بسهولة ،
لكنهم لم يوافقوا ولكن هذا ليس ما
يحدث بالطبع
اعتقد الروس أنه بعد أيام قليلة انتهت الحرب في
أوكرانيا مرة أخرى بعد أيام قليلة  يمكننا أن نسمع
أنها لا تزال مستمرة الآن ، إنها قذيفة
ويمكننا
سماع تحليق القذيفة ، وبعد أشهر ،
خططت الحكومة الروسية
لتحقيق النصر في غضون أيام قليلة ، وأعتقد
أننا يجب أن نكون مستعدين
لجدار طويل من المدفعية
بأسلحة ثقيلة مثل هذا الأوكراني
تم وضع دبابة القتال في خطوط الأشجار
باتجاه عدو غير مرئي ،
وسرعان ما تصبح نقاط إطلاق النار هذه
عرضة للخطر ويجب أن تكون القوات هنا
متحركة ،
حسنًا ، لقد تم إحضارنا إلى
موقع خط المواجهة هذا حيث
سيطلقون النار على القوات الروسية على
مسافة قصيرة.  موقع سري
لا يمكننا البقاء إلا لجولة واحدة
قيل لنا بعد ذلك أنه سيكون هناك
رد إطلاق نار وعلينا الخروج من
هنا ولكن هذا ما تم إحضارنا
لرؤيته
يا إلهي ،
حسنًا
يا رفاق ، ما هو الآن واحد آخر
اعتقدت أنه كان علينا أن نلاحق
مرة أخرى مرة أخرى
بعد ثوانٍ أخرى ، تندفع جولة أخرى تهز العظام
نحو المواقف الروسية ،
حسنًا ، علينا أن
نذهب الآن ، وسرعان ما نترك
الخطوط الأمامية الطاحنة
لأوكرانيا ماثيو  فرصة CNN في جنوب أوكرانيا